hi everyone I am mayank and welcome to
this amazing video on AI in cyber
security by simplina if you enjoy
watching these type of videos and find
them interesting subscribe to our
YouTube channel as we bring you the best
videos daily also hit the Bell icon to
never miss any update from Simply learn
in this video we will Begin by examining
this cyber security and its importance
progressing further our Focus will shift
toward the need for AI and cyber
security
we will then proceed to explore the AI
application in cyber security
going forward we will see the benefits
and challenges of AI in cyber security
after that we will look at some AI tools
used in cyber security in the end we
will see the future landscape of AI and
cyber security before moving on the
cyber security if you are interested in
pursuing a career in cyber security and
acquiring the necessary skills then our
pgp in CS in collaboration with MIT
University is the right option for you
gain expertise in defensive and
offensive cyber security digital
forensic ethical hacking penetration
testing and other crucial domains with
this Industry Program our comprehensive
program offers a curriculum and
compassing various in-demand super
security tools Hands-On labs and guided
practices throughout the course you will
Embark a well-structured Learning
Journey starting with fundamental cyber
security concept and progressing through
asset and inventory management
Python Programming sister administration
of offensive security red team and
defensive security blue team practices
to ensure your Readiness for the
industry you will also engage in
multiple projects allowing you to hone
your skills and emerge as an exceptional
cyber security professional eligibility
criteria for this course is a bachelor
degree with an average of 50 or higher
marks may have non-programming
background
are not required to have prior work
experience
furthermore this course will help you
learn comprehensive approaches to
protecting your infrastructure and
securing data including risk analysis
mitigation and compliance so hurry up
and Define the course Link in the
description box below so without any
further Ado let's dive into what is
cyber security
cyber security Shield Internet connected
devices Hardware software and data from
cyber criminal threats individual and
organization must prevent unauthorized
system access experts train to detect
and hard potential attacks develop
robust strategies against data breaches
and system conferences with increasing
use of devices and programs in modern
Enterprise's cyber security has become a
pivotal defense against the rising risk
of data breaches moving forward let's
see need for AI in cyber security
AI is essential in cyber security due to
the rapidly evolving nature of cyber
security threats as it enhances the
speed and the accuracy of threat
detection automates real-time responses
identifies patterns in data breaches
predict vulnerabilities and strengthens
defense against emerging attack vectors
ultimately providing organization with
the edge needed to effectively Safeguard
digital asset and data in the modern
threat landscape
moving forward let's see AI application
in cyber security
the first one is
real-time analysis of network traffic AI
power tools excel in analyzing Network
traffic patterns strictly identifying
deviation that could indicate a bridge
by continuously monitoring Network
activities AI system can Flex suspicious
behavior and Trigger alerts the second
one is automatic scanning and patching
AI driven vulnerability assessment
automate the process of identifying
weakness in system and software by
promptly defecting vulnerabilities
organization can mitigate potential risk
before attackers can exploit them the
third one is Predictive Analytics for
vulnerability mitigation using
historical data and Predictive Analytics
AI can forecast potential
vulnerabilities and priorities those are
mostly liked to be targeted the fourth
one is analyzing language and context in
message AI employs NLP natural language
processing to scrutinize emails and
messages for the linguistic queues that
suggest phishing attempts the fifth one
is threats and an authorized activities
by monitoring and analyzing user
Behavior AI can detect anomalies that
might indicate Insider thread this asset
in preventing unauthorized activities
can data Bridge from within the
organization let's move forward and see
some benefits of AI in cyber security
the first one is Advanced threat
detection AI system excel at analyzing
vast amount of data in real time
enabling them to detect even subtle
anomalies and patterns indicative of
cyber threats this level of analysis is
beyond the capacity of traditional
rule-based system enhancing the accuracy
of threat detection the second one is
real-time response AI power cyber
security solution can respond to the
threat in real time drastically reducing
this response time compared to manual
intervention the third one is adaptive
security AI system continuously learn
from new data and adapt to changing
attack techniques this adaptability
makes them effective against zero day
vulnerabilities and evolving a tax
pattern the fourth one is phishing
detection AI natural language processing
capability enables it to identify
phishing attempts with high precision
and by analyzing emails for linguistic
queues the fifth one is data analysis AI
data analysis capabilities enable it to
quickly identify Trends and inside
buried within vast amount of data
creating insert detection and decision
making
the last one is cost efficiency while
initial implementation may require
investment AI can lead to long-term cost
saving by reducing the impact of
successful cyber attacks streamlining
operation and optimizing resource
allocation
before moving forward if you are in an
expiring AIML engineer that there is no
better time to train yourself in the
exciting field of machine learning if
you are looking for a course that covers
everything from the fundamentals to
Advanced Techniques look no further than
our Caltech in partnership with IBM this
AIML bootcamp in collaboration with
Caltech will help you advance your
career as AIML especially this AIML
bootcamp includes live classes delivered
by industry expert and Hanson lab and
master classes by Caltech processor
eligibility criteria for this course is
be at least 18 years and have a high
school diploma or equivalent have prior
knowledge or experience in programming
and Mathematics preferably two plus
years of formal work experience so why
wait join now seats are feeling fast
find the course link from the
description box below moving forward
let's use challenges and consideration
the first one is adversarial attacks on
AI hackers exploit AI vulnerability is
demanding vigilating monitoring second
is data privacy versus AI balancing data
analysis and privacy is essential for
Effective cyber security the third one
is bias in AI addressing bias in air
training data ensures equivalent
performance fourth one is human
oversight in air security AI enhance
defenses but human judgment remains
crucial moving forward let's see copy a
base Tools in cyber security the first
one is dark Trace doctor utilize Ai and
machine learning to provide autonomous
threat detection and response across
diverse environments identifying
anomalies and potential threats in real
time the second one is crowdstrike
Falcon crowdstrike Falcon implies AI
driven endpoint protection detecting
preventing threats from across and
the third one is Vector AI Vector AI
specialize in network thread detection
utilizing AI to analyze Network
behaviors and safely identifying and
mitigate cyber threads the fourth one is
silence protect is a Pioneer in using AI
for threat prevention leveraging machine
learning to predict and prevent both
known and unknown malware set the fifth
one is barakuda Center focuses on email
security utilizing AI to identify and
throat spear phishing attempts and
account takeover attacks these top AI
powered cyber security tools demonstrate
the integration of artificial
intelligence to announce difference
mechanisms against an evolving spectrum
of cyber threat
the future landscape of AI and cyber
security AI announced red hunting with
the pivotal and proactively identifying
emerging threats without established
pattern allowing organization to
anticipate and encounter new attacks
Vector advancement in autonomous
security system driven by AI will enable
real-time decision making
and Rapid thread containment reducing
the need for manual intervention
reaching user watching integration will
EI will Revolution style authentication
methods relying Less on traditional
passwords and enhancing security through
behavioral Biometrics and with that we
have come to end of this video on AI and
cyber security I hope you found it
valuable and entertaining please ask any
question about the topic server in this
video on the comment section below our
experts will help you addressing your
problem thank you for watching stay safe
and keep learning staying ahead in your
career requires continuous learning and
upskilling whether you're a student
aiming to learn today's top skills or a
working professional looking to advance
your career we've got you covered
explore our impressive catalog of
certification programs in Cutting Edge
domains including data science cloud
computing cyber security AI machine
learning or digital marketing designed
in collaboration with leading
universities and top corporations and
delivered by industry experts choose any
of our programs and set yourself on the
path to Career Success click the link in
the description to know more
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here
foreign